for a postdoc um and then after students at uh
university of vermont and at northeastern where
he's still affiliated uh he became the managing
director of the pandemic prevention institute
of the rockefeller foundation and a few years ago
also joining our external faculty and in addition
to being a good friend and an excellent cook
um he i i admire his science very much because
he is uh in addition to being one of the
people who's brought network theories away into
epidemiology to handle the many inhomogeneities
and complicated structures of epidemics um he's
also been one of the most visible scientists
in the to kovid and before that um has done
very important work on potassium pertussis and
ebola and anyway it's going to be a great talk so
great well thank you chris very much for that
kind introduction um of course we know that
past success is no guarantee of existing talk
performance so hopefully that hopefully the
talk will be good um and it's wonderful to see so
many friends and colleagues many of you i haven't
seen uh since even before the pandemic but really
thrilled to be here and thrilled to tell you about
some of the work that we've done around stars
code 2 and some of the ways in which i think that
our efforts that have started here at the santa
fe institute from people like professor lawrence
myers and others have really built towards many
of the successes we've had during star spoke too
i know it doesn't necessarily seem like there have
been many successes but i think others certainly
have been one of the things i'm not going to
talk about very much today but i realize maybe
i should have is so sid was asking me about
why things are so hard to forecast and just
as i was leaving santa fe as a postdoc that was
a question i was trying to answer by looking at
the entropy of different infectious disease
time series and the short answer seems to be
infectious diseases are hard to forecast because
the rules that govern them shift in time that's a
bit of a handwave explanation for what's really
going on and so the sort of bayesian learning
thing that we like to do where we aggregate over
lots and lots of time series to try to learn the
model parameters is guaranteed to fail in that
regard and that's of course what we're seeing with
stars code 2 as it plays out now if we want to
know whether there's going to be a surge in new
mexico from this ba.2 variant you may have heard
about well it depends on exactly what's happening
with b82 we still don't know the mechanisms behind
its resurgence um or it's or why it's surging
even in this room everybody's vaccinated
because you have to be to be here
but i don't know what you were vaccinated with
and when i don't know if any of you have had
different stars co2 infections in fact tomorrow
during professor obunu's colloquium talk he's
going to tell us about how the way in
which we conceptualize our environment
at least helps us understand why things
can be so difficult to predict because
if i really want to say something about what's
going to happen in this room i i probably have to
know the state of everybody in this room which is
going to be very very hard to actually measure so
i wanted to start with this quote and i think
that this is fully attributable to professor
dodds at the university of vermont but keep me
honest if it isn't and so one of the things that
that professor does always says is that you should
never bring data to a story planning and that's
that's actually what brandon and i were talking
about just before this is there's this interesting
thing that we've learned about science and science
communication during startups code 2 that it's as
much about being out there talking to people as it
is about being right and one of the things that i
think we have to try to understand is more around
the science of how we actually communicate people
and meet them where they are in terms of deciding
how they're going to behave during a pandemic and
again that to me sounds like a very santa fe
uh institute type of research this is of course
uh kurt bonigan talking about the shape of stories
and i think that one of the things that we can
learn are from the many ways in which people
have tried to conceptualize how things go up and
back down again whether we're talking about the
narrative arc of the story uh or or an epidemic
i'm realizing this is not my first talk i've
given since the pandemic the first one was
actually a yale with with brandon but this is
the first talk where i haven't been trapped
behind a podium because zoom wasn't working and
so i forgot that there's this uh hazard here so
where does all this start in terms of the shape of
epidemics and we've heard a lot about this far's
law we've been paying attention to the covent
forecasts and interestingly with fars law it's
one of these classic old things that everybody
thinks they understand and then when you try to
find the citation for it it turns out you can't
and so i was actually on twitter this morning
trying to find what far actually said about the
shape of epidemics in the 1800s and the citation
trail goes cold pretty fast to a paper in 1975
unfortunately a librarian uh no a professor at the
purdue who i don't know emailed me after seeing
the twitter thread with the actual who bulletin in
the eighteen hundreds not who uh uk bulletin that
far published on but he did say epidemics appear
to be generated at intervals in unhealthy places
spread and go through a regular course in decline
but of the cause of the revolution no more is
known um if the latent cause of epidemics cannot
be discovered the mode by which it operates
may be investigated the laws of its action
may be determined by observation and so far had
this idea that epidemics go up and come back down
symmetrically and we know that isn't true and in
fact far also knew that wasn't true i'm going to
show you quote in a second where far says he
knows that isn't true but he's going to do
it anyways but this piece here the laws of
its action may be determined by observation
we're still arguing about this in the field of
epidemiology and epidemic forecasting whether
one has to actually understand the mechanisms of
spread or whether you can just fit a statistical
model to the data and project that forward in
time and this quote is you know 200 years old
going on and we still don't have a clear agreement
in the field on whether we actually have to know
the mechanism of ba.2 spread if i'm going to
project insurgents or whether i can just fit a
curve to it and run that curve forward in time
now of course interestingly one of the reasons
that we might be so i think in general
short-term epidemic forecasting is
not a solved problem but there are lots of people
who are very good at it the challenge is figuring
out how good is very good because if you take most
infectious disease time series and calculate the
first difference it's basically mean zero with
the constant variance so if i want to predict
how many cases there are tomorrow it's going to be
hard to be just guessing the same number of cases
that we had today you have to get two or three
weeks out before it actually starts to diverge
in a meaningful way in a given flu season flu
kills between 10 and 100 000 people in the u.s
and stars code 2 is 10 times deadlier than fluid
so if you just multiply that by 10 you actually
get right in the range of what happened during the
first year of stars code 2. so again it's actually
in some cases not so hard to make some of these
broad generalizations around forecasting which
means it's even harder to answer this question
about whether understanding the mechanisms matter
if what we care about is prediction right so we
might care just to know the mechanisms because we
want to learn about how the world works but if we
just want to make forecasts it may not be the case
that actually learning the mechanisms helps you
forecast any better than just historical averages
presumably that's a that's a kind of time scale
problem right i mean it's short term versus
medium time skills this is long time skills in
terms of extrapolating some phenomenological fit
to data into the future i mean you know as
scientists we believe that understanding means
that you know maybe at some stage this is going to
break down or not whatever the system is so it's a
you know it's a it's a somewhat it's
it's not just a one-size-fits-all
answer to that question no i think that's
right jeffrey and the i have a slightly more
a slightly different take on that and again i
am wishing that i had talked about this other
paper because i would love all of your opinions
on it but the argument that we make in that paper
is that for the infectious diseases we studied
that the statistical forecast will break down
at the same time as the mechanistic forecasts and
so you can choose your own adventure again if you
care about the mechanism which some of us do i'm
in that camp quite often then that doesn't help
you you have to go out and learn about the
mechanism but if you care about forecasting
one of our claims is that the the statistical
forecast and the mechanistic forecast will fall
apart at about the same time in part because the
mechanisms aren't changing but that's the like
that's the easy way of saying the mechanisms are
changing uh behind the infectious disease process
yeah i mean sort of on that same note it seems
like the back of the envelope flu prediction it's
almost surprising that that does so well because
we don't do societal-wide quarantines around flu
and so it's certain i mean it's from that same
sort of mechanistic thing it's it's actually
you would have i would have guessed the
flu thing should be really far off because
we of course don't respond in the same way
that we did to code well in some ways the not
responding makes it easier right so the the fact
that we keep shifting lockdowns not lockdowns mask
wearing not mask wearing vaccine mandates all of
that probably makes it harder to predict because
you have to understand how people are going
to respond one of the things that's very
clear in the mobility data is people lock
down if they have the privilege to do it
as fast as they get scared and that always
happens before the mandates go in place
an example of this in 2020 massachusetts actually
had the hardest lockdown if you measure people's
displacement from their household but we never
had a mandatory shelter in place order it was a
stern warning from the governor but it's because
people were scared because we massachusetts is
also one of the only places in the u.s where
omicron hasn't eclipsed all previous waves so
this omicron wave has more deaths in the
delta wave in massachusetts but not back
in march of 2020 so in some ways it's that human
behavioral component this work that joshua weitz
has done at georgia tech trying to understand how
if you have even a very simplistic model of the
way because i don't mean to say it's simplistic
it's simple enough that we can understand it
shifting model of human behavior it rapidly
leads to breakdown in the forecast horizon
so just very quickly this was a paper in 1990
published i think in new england journal of
medicine if not they're in an equally prestigious
medical journal where they took data on hiv
aids through basically 1989 and they just fit this
far as law to which assumes you're going to have
a symmetric perfectly symmetric curve and they
estimated that the hiv epidemic pandemic would
end in somewhere between 1994 and 1995 and this of
course is not what happened it's not even close to
what happened and this again is part of the reason
why so many of us were so deeply critical of the
forecasts coming out of the institute for health
metrics and evaluation back in 2020 they literally
just did far's law to estimate how many people
were going to die and when it was going to end
and they were also very arrogant about it and
so i feel like personal taste here you either
can be right and arrogant or wrong and humble i
think right and humble is probably the best but
you don't really want that combination of being
aggressively wrong and arrogant because that also
holds back the science and the public health but
there is something very interesting and i'll come
back to it if i have time journalists still use
these forecasts every single day now thankfully
they've moved on a little bit from fars law they
still use a very very simplistic model in fact
the error the cone of uncertainty shrinks as their
forecast goes out forward in time i can tell you
why that is a very easy thing to trap yourself
into if you're fitting these kinds of models
but journalists use these every single day
and i think it's a pretty simple reason it
goes back to peter dodge's quote about bringing
stories instead of data they made these
readily available at the county level
open source in real time so journalists can take
the open source projections they can reformat
them to match their style guides and they can
run them as infographics on their web page
and it all happens at the county level even the
county level is too course for infectious disease
i'll show you a slide on that in a second but i
really think that's something that we can learn
about the kinds of science we need to be doing
around epidemic forecasting is it has to be hyper
local because that's the only thing people
care about i don't care anymore about what's
going on in washington dc where i live now i care
about what's happening in santa fe and i actually
don't even really care that much about what's
happening in santa fe i want to know i've been
eating outdoors at tune up because they actually
have outdoor dining right now with heaters it's
pretty nice but there's pretty limited outdoor
dining around santa fe is it safe i don't know
it depends on the neighborhood it depends on the
prior rates it depends on all the things i told
you that i don't know about this room to make that
decision of course also depends on my own risk
tolerance and a bunch of other things related to
human behavior but these ihme forecasts it told us
to be popular and to capture attention you don't
need to be right you just need to be relevant
it'd be nice if we could be right and relevant
which is what we're trying to work towards
and you also need to communicate in a format
that is amenable to what people need to do
with the results now again i'm not saying
that all science should conform itself to
relevant and con and you know of use to
journalists but if our goal as epidemiologists
working on pandemics is to try and prevent them
from happening we have to influence people's
behavior we have to influence politicians
we have to be out in the mainstream press
and we can learn quite a bit around sort of the
science of how one might actually do that and in
and of itself raises really interesting scientific
questions how do i generate i've already told you
it's hard to do forecasting why on earth would
i try to make that problem harder by forecasting
at an even finer spatial scale so just just
to show you i'm not making this up so i don't
know this individual eric a lot but i did not do
this work i just took it off of his twitter page
so this is the reported cobin 19 deaths on a
log scale from 2020 through about the present
and the black line here this is what
actually happened and the blue lines
are the forecasts for ihme that underpredicted the
deaths and the red lines are the over prediction
so you can see far's law here right this was their
original forecast the deaths were going to be over
basically by late spring 2020 and then cobia would
be a thing of the past but they continue they they
said they moved off the farms law but they still
have a lot of these models that we know are wrong
and far actually anticipated this so if you
read a little bit further down in the paper
the decline of the epidemic is talking about
smallpox was less rapid than its rockers so he
already says it's not symmetric and the mortality
was somewhat greater in the audience of 1838-1839
than in the summer so there's some kind of
seasonal effect uh but by taking the mean of
the deaths in the third and fourth period the mean
of the deaths in the fourth and fifth period etc
a regular series of numbers is produced so not
surprisingly if you do a bunch of averaging you
get something that looks pretty symmetric and
ignores the spatial variation and the seasonal
variation but all the way back to far he's
telling us that the curves aren't symmetric
then there are many other
factors that one has to consider
so this has led me to this kind of frustration
which is we keep using models we know are wrong
stars h1n1 ebola zika stars co2 i have another
slide here which i stopped using because people
said it was too antagonistic but the science
paper that basically fit a mass action model to
crowded apartment buildings in southeast asia
and extrapolated into toronto has an order of
magnitude more citations than the paper from
lauren anselmeyer and mark newman showing how
to actually do this correctly and get a reasonable
estimate of the stars co2 risk and so again it's
this science communication piece it's why we still
have far's law being done by the institute for
health metrics and evaluation than the white house
using this why we still have mass action models
that are ubiquitous is because the first science
paper that comes out about sars fits the mass
action model and so the next times it comes comes
around it seems like a totally reasonable thing
to do same with h1n1 ebola zika stars code two
i have a version of this talk that i give where
there were two very prominent medical journals
that published essays saying the risk of sustained
sexual transmission of zika is low and so for
those of you that aren't aware zika even though
it's a mosquito borne virus can be transmitted
from person to person via sexual intercourse and i
called up lauren bear dufresne who's known to many
of you as a professor at the university of vermont
i said lauren what do we know about a vectored
pathogen that is also sexually transmitted in
terms of just the physics like just tell me
that you have a model sitting on your shelf
that answers the question how likely is this to
be stable in the simplest case and laurent says
nobody knows anything because nobody ever knew
that that could happen nobody ever thought that
there would be a mosquito-borne disease that
would be sexually transmitted and i said well
why are there very prominent medical journals
saying that it's not possible and so we looked
and they'd taken a model with mass action mixing
and applied it to sexually transmitted infections
and came to the conclusion that it's very
unlikely under that scenario that it can be
maintained endemically and it turns out as
soon as you relax that and put in realistic
sexual contact networks it's very likely
to be maintained endemically what's your
double asterisks yeah you can't see so i don't
i'm not saying who these i guess i have said
some of these people are but um and the second
week is probably not the same sunset as the
first week although here's the interesting
evolution of my thought presence on this
how does this thing work
so with antoine lard jean gabriel
young and lorraine bernie fraim we've
been working on this kind of problem
and i'm now even more confused about
how we should be thinking about these
wrong models and i'll tell you why so
we did this work while lauren and i were
post-docs here at the santa fe institute and
antoine was visiting uh also as a postdoc and
we took this influenza time series in the u.s
and what i've highlighted in red here are all
the places where the rate of spread is faster
than you would predict given the early dynamics
so we just look at this early part of the curve
we say how fast is this spreading and then we
ask is it spreading about the same rate or is
it spreading faster as you get closer to the
beach and every single season in the united
states including all of the 2009 endemic waves the
rate of spread as you hit the peak is faster than
the early spread and it turns out that nobody had
pointed this out before so forecasting these time
series is a multi-million dollar industry in
the united states and nobody had ever noticed
that if you fit to the early part of the curve
the growth rate's always faster and nobody had
pointed out that there isn't a single model that
allows this to happen that has been published the
most common model is a seasonal forcing model for
flu where you go from subcritical to critical by
increasing the reproductive number at a particular
time point so that doesn't give you this so it's
already super critical here it just speeds up
as it comes to the beach so it's not that much
which is the opposite of what farsil would do
yes it's the opposite of what everything would be
now so we looked at
trouble
we looked at a very specific model that we
thought would generate these data which is
as an instructor if i get sick i'm probably going
to be replaced by somebody who can teach for me
but interestingly i actually have quite a
bit of information about the conditional
probability that somebody in my social
network is sick because i'm sick i had
to have gotten it from somebody even if
it's aerosol it's still a physical process
and so if i take chris who's not sick i
actually have some conditional probability
about chris's area which is he's probably in a
safer part of the network and so i'm going to
take somebody from a relatively safe part of the
network and rewire them into an area where i'm
probabilistically less safe and in practice
what this does is it takes lots of edges that
would say be like a susceptible susceptible head
so like prison branding connects to each other
and rewire them to create more susceptible
infectious benches which is what governs
how these epidemic models work
in the simplest network case
but it takes a little bit of time to build up
enough individuals such that you really see
this rewiring effect and it leads to this kind of
phenomenological effect where all of a sudden it
just takes off it's spreading really fast and then
you build up enough individuals enough of these
like susceptible infectious edges being rewired
that you get a shift in the dynamics and that's
what we're showing here in this figure so this is
the infection rate divided by the recovery rate
and the proportion infectious equilibrium so this
is the susceptible infectious susceptible models
and we use this to illustrate the
point because it's easier to solve
so this is the rate at which individuals
go from infectious back to susceptible
and this is the rate at which they go from
susceptible to infectious governed also by the
contact process and depending on the particular
parameter combination because this is an infinite
population there will be a fixed percentage
of people that are infectious at equilibrium
so this is the proportion infections at
equilibrium for three different rates
of replacement so gamma is how fast i rewire those
infectious teachers so at the lowest rate here
you can keep the proportion infections at
zero so in the subcritical phase until you get
a sufficiently infectious virus relative
to the recovery rate and then you get this
smooth transition into uh endemic equilibrium
that basically is a governed by you know the
rate of infection and you increase the rate of
spread and you can push the system a little bit
further so you can have an even more infectious
virus and still control it but once you get to a
really high rate of replacement you end up with a
situation where you can push the system really far
really really infectious pathogens but as soon
as you get this transition it's discontinuous
and we were able to prove this analytically
it was discontinuous because of the presence
of this hysteresis loop and so if you want to
then drive the system back into the zero endemic
state you have to do a whole lot more work than
you did when you went in this direction however
this isn't the only model that looks like this
and turns out this is the only model that can
explain these data so now this is a paper
by lauren very friend and ben althouse they
wrote this while they were postdocs here you
have again basically this is the fraction of
susceptible edges in the population in the
network model versus the force of infection
for two different pathogens that
are spreading on the same network
and they're either interacting with each
other or not interacting with each other
and they're either doing this on a clustered
network or an unclustered network and it turns
out that this interacting pathogens you end up
with the same kind of effect as this replacement
of individuals so you build up enough infection
of pathogen a that all of a sudden pathogen b can
sweep through the population and if you're
just looking so this time series for flu
i'm going to get this point right before
the end of the talk this time series for flu
this is actually not influenza these are
case reports of symptoms of people who meet
the symptom definition for influenza we've
looked using multi-panel pcr tests and any
one of these given curves is typically only 20
fluids 80 other respiratory pathogens and the 80
other respiratory pathogens is different
from season to season so this could be
interacting pathogens and we just wouldn't know
it because we just get one time series to look at
so we wanted to think about
this particular problem
and it turns out that there's a third model that
gives this same effect and this is a model from
the social sciences basically it's the voter model
so the way that brandon's going to decide whether
to tweet about this talk or not it certainly
depends a little bit on brandon's current state
but what he's going to do is he's going to look
around at his neighbors and see who's tweeting
and the way he's going to decide is he's not going
to tweet if it's just chris he's not going to
tweet if it's chris and one other person or
chris and two other people but as soon as
five or more other people are tweeting then
brandon will tweet with probability one so you
have this kind of like step function that
governs the probability of tweeting where
tweeting is now considered being infectious and
this same model gives us this burstiness for lack
of a better word that you get in the teacher
replacement model and also in the interactive
looked at this and here is the basically
proportioned infections at equilibrium
uh this is again beta
divided by some recovery rate
and here we're looking what you end up with is
that the beta becomes a function of the proportion
infectious so beta actually change the effect of
beta changes in time as the proportion infectious
increases what i'm showing you here is a model
of interacting contagion and a model of complex
contagion and they are exactly the same so it
turns out that all models of interacting pathogens
can be mapped onto a complex contagion model where
in this case the complex contagion model is a high
degree polynomial that governs that step function
which can be smooth now and what's interesting
there is the interacting pathogen model if i
want to fit it to data i've got to have two times
just given the number of parameters and
the identifiability of them in the model
but for this complex contagion model i actually
only need one time series to fit my polynomial
and as soon as i have my polynomial i
can then forecast out into the future
and actually get really accurate forecasts even
for a model that i absolutely know is wrong
and in this case it's because essentially the
physics of these complex contagions are identical
to these interacting pathogens now it turns out
that's not true for arbitrary networks you can
in this case we're showing this for the mass
action model but you can of course come up
with a pathological network but this won't be
the case but for many of our favorite stylized
networks so can you remind me with beta on
the second on the plot right it was beta of
yeah i'll explain it here because i think this
is easier to see so it turns out the effect of
this is that so beta normally is a fixed parameter
in the model and that it's typically a combination
of the per contact probability of infection and
the mixing rate so in a mass action case it's the
mixing rate rho times the per contact probability
of transmission here what we're saying is
the effective beta is a function of the proportion
infections in the population so now if i want to
know at any given time in the model or maybe time
is just proportional infectious if i want to know
how fast this thing is spreading you tell me what
the proportion infections are i plug this into my
high degree polynomial and i get a number out the
other side and so what we look for here this blue
is a model that it doesn't have this complex
contagion process although interestingly you
always tend to get a little bit of a speed up as
you get to really high proportioned infections
this model has the complex contagion process
and so you can see how beta increases rapidly as
you have more and more a higher
and higher percentage infections
and we looked at this in the context of a few
different infectious diseases so dengue you see
a little bit of that trend zika we had to do
some creative prior distributions to get this
model to converge and so this is basically just
the prior so just think about this as being flat
so zika there's no evidence for this kind
of process and then influenza there's a huge
amount of evidence it goes over basically two
orders of magnitude depending on the proportion
infectious so what we can conclude from this is
one of two different things and gengablerod are in
one camp but i'm in the other camps so they're in
the camp of this is awesome we can fit this model
to a single time series and we can forecast and
i'm in the other camp which is i probably can't
tell you what the mechanisms are without a
bunch of additional data and or assumptions
what are the little vertical ticks these are
just where we actually observe data in terms
of our model fit so we have a bunch of models
that we're fitting across different values of
okay then what is the eye of tower in sets
uh this is the actual proportion infectious
so these are the epidemic curves how is time yeah
some time okay uh we ran out of parameters so um
interestingly and this is to the
question that sid was asking me earlier
you might say well couldn't i just learn the
parameters of this high degree polynomial for flu
and then when i see the next flu season
couldn't i just plug in the proportion
infections and make my forecast and
the answer is no so if we go back to
this time series if we do the exercise of fitting
this high degree polynomial to each flu season
you have different parameterized polynomials for
all the flu seasons so basically every single
flu season there's some evidence for either a
complex contagion process or interacting pathogens
or something else that we don't know about or this
teacher replacement model but it's different every
single year so i can't just say learn that
function over here and plug it into forecast
in the future
so this is just an example
there's some interesting things so
i've yet to find an infectious disease paper
where people are claiming it's a complex contagion
if anybody's aware of what i'd love to hear
where you actually have this threshold effect
so complex contagion means this sort of
granovetter-like threshold infection that's
what that's what that phrase means yes yeah um
because you can also imagine contagions where
there's a lot of internal state and memory of
some non-markovian thing going on because they're
in hidden states i i think the argument
would be that we would be able to model those
with this process for a single time series but
that laurent and jengar may be listening and
putting their heads in their hand as i'm saying
that but i think that that is a claim again
not for probably in the markovian case not for
any arbitrary amount of memory and in fact the
giving petri and i who is principal researcher at
the isi foundation he and i wrote this paper on on
entropy and disease forecasting and our favorite
explanation for what's really going on is it's
maybe not so much that the models are shifting
it's that if you sort of think about it like
life for back lack of a better word has infinite
memory or at least back all the way to the
beginning and you have to account for that state
properly if you're going to do the forecasting
and i think that's kind of where we are with kobit
right now which is my claim at the beginning so if
i wanted to make a good forecast even if sid gave
me the model i would have to gather a lot of very
detailed data on this room before i would be able
to actually use that model to make a forecast so
here's a couple of other here's something else
that we don't see so you can also get this tab
yes and so right there's also these weird
and density dependent models where you
assume that you need some threshold of
viral uh load in order to to be infected
yes and they they would also give
you a like an increase in uh rate and
uh hysteresis and things like that that's
right and i actually think for me um
and maybe i'll just i'm gonna skip ahead so
i'm gonna run out of time to tell you about
some of the more interesting things so i have
to tell you about it over t um our suspicion is
that you know there's approximately n people that
work on infectious diseases and there's probably
n minus one or n squared models that have
been proposed somewhere in that range
and probably some very small subset of them are
actually different from each other in terms of
what you might expect to see in the data that
we have and that's that was my other that's my
throwaway answer to this question about why things
are so hard to predict it's that we have this
very haphazard course observational lens that all
of our data come into when we make these kinds
of projections right and so why would i ever
forecast influenza data at the national level
why would i ever forecast anything at the national
level if you think back to the omicron wave
that was 90 new york city up until relatively
recently if you go back to the first wave in the
u.s again it was 90 new york city in boston in
march of 2020 so why on earth would i just add
a bunch of additional noise by trying to forecast
the 50 cases in houston and the 300 cases in los
angeles et cetera so there's this granularity
question and the data question there's a whole
bunch of models that seem to produce basically the
same physics and pulling apart what is actually
making this a hard problem to solve i think
is a very open question right so is it really
the case as per my earlier claim that the sort
of regularized state space is shifting in time
such that you can't learn a model and then use it
to forecast or is it just our observational model
is changing but the underlying model structure is
perfectly stable and we can learn parameters and
forecast brilliantly into the future is it
something else um an interesting thing is you
can get this negative reinforcement but i don't
think i've seen this for infectious diseases you
see this a lot on twitter so these are social
media uh mentions about walter cronkite dying
and so here's proportion infectious beta i
and so you remember it's going up for all
these infectious disease models you get this
kind of negative reinforcement where people
become increasingly less likely to tweet as they
see their neighbors tweeting less and less sorry
i know you want to move on but uh all of these
curves from the uh the increasing side of the peak
yes okay all right so none of these are
describing what happens on the other side
and i i mean the flu peaks
are fascinating because the
the derivative looks just continuous there
because you could so you would have another
inference problem with different uh results if you
use the back side yes so great point chris and um
that is actually now where we think most
of the information about mechanism comes in
is on the right hand side of the peak so if
we go back to this teacher replacement model
i was telling you about now imagine that we're
in the susceptible infectious recovered state
so there's some individuals that
are immune or we vaccinated them
and the only rule is i have to replace you
with someone who's not sick so i don't i don't
ascertain your status aside from whether you're
sick or not which means i can also replace you
with recovered individuals so what you end
up having is you get this super rapid rise
in infections as you approach the beat but then
you've built up a lot of recovered individuals and
you start to rewire these edges to ir edges which
slam the brakes on the epidemic and you get this
very very rapid decline whereas in the complex
contagion case you actually have a much slower
relaxation on the right hand side of
the curve so our current hypothesis
is that if you care about the mechanism
and you only have one time series and again
for those of you who don't work on epidemics
again not to sit and i only talk for five minutes
it's amazing that i have so many things to say
about it but i was telling sid one of the most
wonderful things about the past two years is that
all of a sudden everybody cares about these really
hard problems that we've been working on for 10
years and so the question then becomes you know
why do you only have one time series whatever
why why do you keep making the problem harder and
that's because you know we're constrained by data
et cetera et cetera but we think if you only have
one time series you have to wait until it starts
to come down before you're really going to be able
to distinguish from some pretty different models
right so in terms of how you might intervene
in the epidemic if it's an interacting pathogen
you would do something very different i assumed
that if it was a voter model that if it was
replacing teachers uh or if it was something else
and in fact this is one of the things that that
professor is going to tell us about tomorrow
there does seem to be this dichotomy going
all the way back to genetics at the turn of
the last century between what you can
do if you make some assumptions about
the kind of phenomenological
process and your ability to predict
versus if you want to go in and intervene at the
very local level where you probably have to know
the mechanism and there's this kind of the two
are not incompatible they're totally compatible
with each other unless you want to intervene
and then it turns out if you don't understand
who do i need to go and vaccinate me because i
then have to know the mechanism and i actually
think i know a lot of people that are working
on this room it's a very interesting question in
terms of what the point of the forecast is going
to be and what we need to know about the messages
so this is some work that came out of brandon's
lab and this paper was led by amazing phd student
loris gomez and this largely came out of models of
say hepatitis where you think there's an infected
needle that's being passed around or models of
cholera where there's an infected water source
and they call this the sit and wait
model weight stands for something
and the idea is that there's essentially an
environmental reservoir so you you do have a
contact process where people are transmitting
to each other but you also have some other
environmental reservoir where people are going to
that reservoir and picking it up themselves and so
the way they model this is you have susceptible
individuals exposed so there's some lag you have
some asymptomatic individuals this turns out
to be really important for our observational
models that a lot of people are asymptomatic
and they're infectious we can never see them
this is work that ben and i did on whooping cough
at the santa fe institute that led to a book
uh and a bunch of additional work around how
you study asymptomatic infections then people
are infectious and they recover but there's
also this pernicious environmental reservoir
that's infecting people uh directly and then
there are people that are depositing including the
asymptomatic individuals and we wrote this paper
variation in micro parasite free living survival
and direct transmission to modulate the intensity
of emerging outbreaks we wrote this paper because
back in february of 2020 there was a study
looking at survival of stars co2 virus on surfaces
and sarge 1 and stars 2 have about the same
survival on everything which is not very long
except for cardboard where stars code 2 survives
twice as long as stars one and brandon and i are
sitting there thinking well what have we
done since stars one back in 2003 we have
covered the entire world in cardboard and maybe
this explains something about what's going on
now he he and i both think we're probably wrong
on that now but part of the reason it took so long
to convince ourselves we were wrong is this
model with the reservoir component fits
data from 15 or 20 countries far better than
this model without the component and this is the
dominant modeling paradigm for starter scope 2.
is this scion process and so what we were actually
then starting to think about is what is this model
really telling us this isn't anything specific
about an environmental reservoir this is instead
capturing something about our uncertainty and how
we learn about the process or the model itself or
understand the dynamics of what's happening with
the pathogen another way to think about
this is this is also evidence for aerosol
transmission so i mentioned it's still
a physical process even if it's aerosol
well aerosol is going to break down that effect of
direct social networks not as much as surface
transmission but it will break this down and
so one of the things then that we're trying
to understand is what are the consequences of
this model uncertainty in the public
health context and so as chris mentioned
i left northeastern to join the rockefeller
foundation they made a 100 million investment
in pandemic prevention and the goal is to sit
right at this interface between our basic science
understanding about how pandemics work about human
behavior but how you actually operationalize it
and so this is really going to force us
to answer this question does it matter
how accurate my time series forecasts are
if we can't actually intervene on them
and then if we do need to understand
mechanism in order to intervene
how do we go about learning that mechanism and
am i right that there is this sort of nihilistic
view that we might take to this which is as
soon as we have enough data to learn the model
it's old news now the one thing
i would add that's sort of a
i'm going to say one thing
before i go to the end here
herd immunity threshold is a fantasy it doesn't
exist out of the side of the thermodynamic limit i
don't think it has any good definition in a finite
sized population for what people want it to mean
endemicity basically relies on the herd immunity
threshold so endemicity is where you would have
r equal one and that's also basically the herd
immunity threshold so endemicity is just as much
of a fantasy as herd immunity threshold but
it turns out there's still quite a bit about
the map even in these infinite population
models that we don't understand yet and it
thinks about the behavior and the social
networks that we don't understand so
we've been working on super spreading events for
a while trying to actually quantify what we mean
by a super spreading event how do you actually
parameterize super spreading events how do you
make it rigorous in terms of is this number
of cases really surprisingly large relative
to the first and second moment of the
distribution of secondary cases that
kind of thing and then how does that feed into the
herd immunity thresholds in these stylorx models
and we were talking with chris and chris said wait
wait wait that actually makes another assumption
which is that you're in degree and you're out
degree are the same so setting aside the fact
that the herd immunity threshold doesn't have
a meaning and endemicity doesn't have a meaning
even in the infinite population models in
a social network you still have to assume
something that we don't know is true in order
to say have a quick movement to hurt immunity if
you vaccinate the high degree individuals that
assumes that they're in degree and out degree
are tightly coupled so that's this month high risk
of spread high risk of infection well why couldn't
there be people that are at low risk of getting
infected but at very high risk of spreading maybe
let's think about a physician wearing lots of ppe
very low risk of getting infected but if for some
reason they did get infected they might expose
50 or 100 or 200 people what about high risk
of infection but low risk of spread these people
probably exist too so we worked on this and it
turns out that the dynamics are almost entirely
driven by the unique so if the in degree is
poisson the system behaves like it's entirely
poisson even if the out degree is scale free
so not only do we make this assumption we're
over here we were able to show that if it
turns out the assumption is violated you have
different in and out degrees in some cases it
might be totally fine to use mass action random
mixing on a social network because it basically
behaves like it's poisson anymore and in other
cases that's going to be wildly misleading
so the one sort of positive
thing that i'll mention
is here so duncan watts peter dodds and
colleagues published this paper i think in 2004
in pnas where they looked at what happens when you
have an epidemic model spreading in a hierarchical
meta-population so imagine like we're in
households those households are in neighborhoods
those neighborhoods are in cities those cities
are in cities et cetera et cetera and what they
were able to show is that in a single population
it's like a one deemed model to use them out of
population language from ecology you get one wave
almost looks a little farty and although this
is coming out a little slower if you have two
layers and there's some stochasticity here you
basically get two wings as it gets into one part
of the network and then gets into the second
part of the network and as you have increasing
number of layers you get this increasing smear
in the cases and this is my favorite paper
by professor staton spiel and herring
they took data from the hudson burr hudson bay fur
trading company during the 1918 flu pandemic the
fur traders signing in and out of the log books
to parameterize a hierarchical meta population
of 1918 flu and show that this process was
happening this paper i think came out before the
the watson hall paper so you get these multiple
waves they predict in the different fur trading
camps given their connectivity structure so what
we did is we said well maybe one of the reasons
that cobit seems to never go away in sao paulo
and new york city and others but it goes like a
flash in the pan in places like manaus and other
areas is that this the degree of hierarchy within
the city is going to affect how long the epidemic
will be able to persist essentially through these
meta-population dynamics and we showed using data
from china and italy which were two places that
had completed their epidemic their first evidence
that this holds over multiple orders of magnitude
in terms of city size and epidemic duration that
it's the hierarchy in terms of how these places
are organized that governs how long something
is going to stay present in the population and
this also to go back to the rockefeller side leads
to a bunch of really important predictions about
how you might prepare for something like this so
it turns out that we did some simulation models
and it's true if you're in the basically the one
beam model and you have everybody locked down
that this flattens the curve however if
you're in the multi-hierarchy network
having everybody locked down actually
intensifies the curve because you have
so much more transmission in the household and
people spend a higher proportion of their time
locked down in the household and so if you're
worried about hospitals getting overwhelmed
in some regimes lockdowns help and in other
regimes they might actually make things worse in
addition the sort of instantaneous demand on the
hospitalizations is going to be highest in rural
areas where you tend to have much closer knit
communities with much less hierarchical structure
however i know many of you in the room work
on this and you're kind of rolling your
eyes a little bit because that's a very coarse
characterization of urban versus rogue radiance
the other thing that this does is highlight the
importance of really understanding how these
cities and areas are organized being able to
monitor and measure them because if we're going to
go in and make specific recommendations about how
to control pandemic i need to know something about
the contact distribution the degree of hierarchy
how that's shifting in time as we open in closed
schools et cetera and it's not like it matters
a little bit it's the difference between either
flattening the curve or filling up the hospitals
so figuring out both our observation model and
additional things around the basic science
of these infectious diseases are critical
for how you actually would operationalize
this in the context of preventing penalties so
this is why i'm ending here with why am i so
critical of it to me because this is a group
that since day one of the epidemic has prioritized
publicity over scientific accuracy now one i don't
know how we define scientific accuracy in the
context of what i've just talked about but i
think we can try to figure out how we actually do
both if that's what we care about and again that's
a very sfi problem so how do we make something
go viral in terms of our communication and how
do we link that back to accuracy and how do we
even define what we mean by accuracy and i'll
just mention the last one so i have a bunch of
things here that i think we could probably work on
as a community so i'm going
to get this up here we go so
training for the next generation of health
data researchers and policy makers so i know
that sfi has a long history of say bringing
in science journalists and embedding them
in the sfi both so that the researchers build
relationships with the science journalists
but also so that science journalists get an
opportunity to interface with the researchers
i can have i mean obviously we have the world's
best post-doctoral program when it comes to
training the next generation of thinkers like this
but you could imagine bringing in individuals like
policymakers for periods of time either as
workshops or embedding them at the institute
where you really start to train the next
generation of decision makers how to process
these sorts of complex adaptive systems models all
these different layers that you have to integrate
that lead to major structural
differences in how you might
intervene so again i want chris thanks for the
introduction thank you all very much for attending
please be sure to come by for brandon's
talk tomorrow it's going to be fantastic and
i know we're in time but i i can stick it
around and answer questions you're not over
the only reason i was on time for
the talk is because i forgot that
clock was fast and the only reason i was
on time for finishing is i forgot to talk
so that the talk is working yeah so yeah i was
just curious do you have any idea like suppose
that this pandemic started like 200 years
ago before there's any medical intervention
you know would this have taken over the world if
we had no medical intervention i don't think so
so the early data from wuhan suggested that there
was probably probably 90 percent of introductions
were going to go locally extinct just because
of stochastic effects so the thing with super
spreading right is the biggest effect on super
spreading is on the establishment probability so
if if an infectious disease is first moment it's
always shown in the paper with laurent and antoine
and then if the infectious disease's first moment
is high because it's propped up by super spreading
that means that you have a second moment that
makes it likely to stochastically go extinct
before it becomes established and so we show in
this paper is that the establishment probability
is often very very low for these
diseases that rely on super spreading
once they become established they can often
march along deterministically largely governed by
the first moment of the number of secondary
infections but back in wuhan it looked like
we see this up and down the west coast of the
u.s there are many many introductions that never
took off so i actually probably think without
the high degree of connectivity now even without
medical intervention i think nothing's impossible
but i would say it's pretty unlikely that
osiris-co2 would would take
off the other side of that is
i think the evidence is probably stronger
for natural origin i don't think we've ruled
out the lab rules but here's why i think it is
actually really important to answer that question
setting aside the desire to know if it
wasn't a lab weed we could probably fit
an earthquake type model and estimate
that there must have been ten thousand a
hundred thousand a million spillovers that
never went anywhere before we got the one
bonanza and so what does that mean for the
surveillance models that we're trying to build
we're gonna get a million false positives for
every hit to respond so one i think probably not
two i think it raises a lot of questions around
how we need to think about the risk of spillover
in the context of what happened in in if it
wasn't the last week if it was a lovely then
we have a very simple answer which is an answer
actually mark lipsticks told us at the stanford
institute 10 years ago which we have to stop
doing these gain of function experiments and we
need better laboratory protocols but we need to
do that regardless of whether it was a lab week
graham has a question yeah sam uh
hi sam thanks for for a great talk
uh i i was uh heartened to
hear you talk about narrative
at the beginning and also uh communication and i
think you must have learned more than most people
about communicating your science over the past
couple of years probably with some ups and downs
and uh it's something we all need to do better
do you have a i mean what's your advice uh
yeah thanks sam and actually we should talk
because one of the the instructions we got
from the santa fe and spent on san francisco
from our board of trustees at rockefeller is
working to link these kinds of things to economic
policy because i'm actually not at all convinced
that good public health isn't also good for the
economy um and that's a that is definitely a well
ingrained misnomer in my opinion but of
course the nuances the details will matter so
the short answer is it's the omidyard fellowship
at the santa fe institute so you know we had
people come in and work with us in groups and in
one on one on communicating our assignments we had
journalists embedded here many of the first calls
i got were from people who had done the journalism
fellowship at sfi and they had my phone number and
email address as a result and so they reached out
and called but i also learned a lot of things from
like from john german and others who would sit
down and coach me okay if you're not live you're
always allowed to re-record here's what these
things are the basic sort of vocabulary around
interacting with journalists so that's the first
thing is that i think at least for me i can point
all roads back to the professional development
work at sfi the second is my relationship with the
journalists shifted so in the past if i ever got a
press inquiry chris would reach out as a
journalist from such and such you have a very
specific question you want to ask about a paper
and then chris would be gone from my life forever
whereas in the new model chris is calling every
week because chris has to file stories every week
and so we build up a relationship and there's
a lot more trust i can be open with chris
because chris and i have an understanding i
know where he's where he's going those sorts
of things and again some of that does come back
to the types of things we're doing at santa fe
the other part of course is like now coming over
to the rockefeller foundation northeastern was
great i had really incredible support from their
comms team but they were totally overwhelmed
because there's a shopping list of researchers
that were you know being asked to do media at
the rockefeller foundation we have an incredible
team that works with us you know coaching us on
live interviews and sitting in on calls and
working on our answers for journalists and so
the third answer is just practicing coaching from
experts which i guess is also the first answer
thanks a lot
so i i totally agree with your uh diagnosis of
how the ihme thing became so convincing that and
i guess i don't know if they have people there
on staff that create these beautiful interactive
atlas and so on i mean my my most cited paper
which is because one of my young co-authors had
the wherewithal to put it on github and make
it easily usable and all that kind of stuff
um but i in addition to their uh let's go
ahead and say violation of intellectual
standards um there was there was also this really
ludicrous example of completely motivated modeling
namely the so-called cubic
model which you know it was like
this was something where instead of fitting
a quadratic to the logarithm you fit a cubic
which means that depending on the sign of the
third coefficient either uh the entire universe
will be infected or absolutely no one will be
in fighting time and i guess that came out of
the white house and there was actually a nobel
prize-winning economist involved but i mean that
was like sort of the most shameful example of in
that case the deliberate misuse while cloaking it
in the appearance of sophistication and so on
how how do you is there any hope of like punching
through that kind of thing because it you know
more people have these tools now than used to
which means that there can be some real
charlatan breed which from the point of view
of a late person looks just as much like science
as science does i don't know to be honest because
i mean i think one take home from some of the
models we've been doing is that there's always
a model that will tell the story you want
to tell me and if you think in cubic it's
bad wait do you see the polynomial that
we fit for some of these months right
um yes but you're not trying to produce a
result for the policy maker you work for
oh but it's i think it's brandon and i
were actually talking about this before
it's raised a lot of questions that i think a
number of us have been wrestling with i mean
what is the purpose of peer review when the
science is basically being adjudicated in
the new york times and the wall street journal in
terms of what the public and the white house care
about and if that's the case why wouldn't you just
go public with your work as fast as you possibly
can and we saw that right so the pre-prints were
even too slow for researchers people just started
posting the white papers on their website
so that you didn't have the 24-hour delay
coming out of the preprints i think
some of it you know it has to be
on this training side for policy makers
you have to believe that people want to do the
right thing otherwise it's just totally hopeless
we know there's some people that don't i think the
other thing that's changed and a very prominent
professor just wrote about this in a very
prominent journal where he was reporting that one
of his biggest problems that all his detractors
have too many social media followers now
basically what he means is that carl bergstrom is
being pointing out all the flaws in his work and
carl now has 400 000 people to follow him there
is a really different thing that's true now about
scientists i we have friends and colleagues
who two years ago they were well known in
our spaces and some of them had published
popular books and were kind of well known
but now there are some of these people that are
household names and they have follower accounts
that are way up into the influencer level and
so i do think we have some additional tools in
terms of our ability to reach people um and we've
seen some of the power of social media i think we
we have to not be afraid to engage with it so this
is the other thing brandon i were talking about is
some of the folks that annoy me the most are
incredibly popular and people point to them as
like the sages when it comes to cobin and i can
build a really good forecasting model which is
just whatever they say to the officer because
they've been wrong about absolutely everything
and nobody seems to care they're just out there
talking about the science they're communicating
with people now one thing that does happen is
that they tend to own up to it really quickly
they say oh yeah i was wrong we're just trying
to move fast this is how science works you have
to evolve et cetera but i do think again if we
care about if we if we admit that we're fighting
massive disinformation campaigns and we're going
to set aside anti-backs because that's been around
for 250 years we're not gonna 30 of the people
we're never going to reach in that case but
we have to be willing to go into the social
media side we have to be willing to go into
the print journalism on the television but that's
a very different skill set for how you actually do
that but it's also a very different skill set
for how you actually successfully communicate
something that's complex and nuanced in a way
that you feel comfortable with as a scientist
and a communicator but it's also going to
capture people's attention and influence
their behavior and again i think that that's
a very sfi style problem what's like how
efficiently can you communicate something that
we know is literally complex by the definition
i don't know i'm skeptical but yeah question
um yeah that was an excellent talk um this is
jeremy just good to see you even you're writing um
but so i was wondering i you know i spent some
time on the cdc's website looking at their cd
their projections so could you say a little bit
about what so after it seems like you know two
years cgc does have this sort of model averaging
collection i forget it's this guy from was it
from from umass or something but so you meant
ampers nicholas right yeah i said a little bit
more about that and like and and they they seemed
to especially during omicron they were you know
stop they stopped even offering the
projection at least for cases so like
how good is it are people actually using this
model averaging approach that they're doing or
yeah great question and i think it raises a
bunch of really interesting kind of follow-ons so
if i think the right model
is somewhere in that ensemble
then probably averaging is the worst possible
thing i can do right because i'm just averaging
a bunch of wrong models in with my right marble
so the fact that it does seem to work pretty well
i think in and of itself is
an important piece of data um
the cdc has invested a lot in trying to build
this forecasting capacity but also importantly
build our capacity to actually ensemble the models
and compare them so you know 10 years ago it would
have been impossible to do this because the models
would have been the outputs of the models would
have been incompatible people weren't sharing
them the inputs would be totally incompatible
the questions they're asking and answering so in
some ways it's been huge progress we know these
models are tend to be much more accurate
than many of the ones that i've discussed
so far i think it raises a really interesting
question about if we really think these are the
most accurate models what it tells us about the
mechanistic structures that are in any of those
individual models within the
ensemble but i think your last point
turning off the forecasts creates an
information vacuum that will be filmed
and so brandon and i again we're talking
about this there's this real tension between
scientists of like i don't want to go out if i'm
wrong i don't want to go out too early i don't
want to you know say things where i think there's
too much uncertainty and all of those are true
but if we don't go out there then somebody will
and that information vacuum will be
filled and so coming up with ways in which
you know the the forecasts that we think are more
reliable in principle don't get turned off right
when everybody needs them is that's something
that we're going to have to do some reckoning
around and i'm hopeful i know the cdc has this new
forecasting center that's one of the things that
they're going to try to work on it's of course
hard to do this work as an academic because
you know you're not you don't have the staff
and you don't have the resources to be working
you know 24 hours a day seven days a week
as a part of an omicron response that's
something that you need federal government
level dollars to work on does that answer the
question sort of yeah and i think i thought
it was interesting even just looking at the
they weren't offering case projections
during omicron because of how the uncertainty
but even people on twitter like even were getting
approximately when i was gonna pick people were
saying you know third week fourth week of january
and even though the the case projections on cdc's
site weren't saying that even the back of the
envelope sort of intuition we had so it goes back
to sort of your original point about being able
to make rough calculations about the behavior and
somehow getting it right as much as the complex
models were so no i think that's exactly right i
mean i know certainly i was saying that i don't
have any special insight but if something goes
up this fast it's going to peak pretty quickly
it should come down sort of fast too and you
can just eyeball it and get pretty close which
again i think tells us something interesting
about what's going on and maybe how we should be
looking at some of these problems awesome well
i know we're over time thank you all very much
um everybody anyone who's still online and but